Duke and Duchess of Sussex confirm that
they have been asked to vacate their
Royal residents at Frogmore Cottage
outside London which was given to them
in 2018 by the lake Queen Elizabeth II a
British tabloid reports that King
Charles plans to move his brother prince
Andrew into Frogmore as Andrew is not a
working Royal anymore Buckingham Palace
has not commented well this morning Roya
Nica Royal editor of Britain Sunday
Times told us that vacating Harry and
Megan is a quote bold move from King
Charles and Roy's words it sends a
strong signal that he doesn't really
care about the Optics and is much Keener
to get his ducks in a row in terms of
who lives where and what their duties
are